zone europe bonjour et bienvenue dans un
europe / sensation une émission
enregistrée au parlement européen de
bruxelles
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
l'eurodéputée sylvie brunet sera
l'invité de corentin alonso l'occasion
d'évoquer la précarité des travailleurs
européens
les pères fondateurs de l'europe vous
nous vous parlerons de conrad adenauer
un fervent défenseur du projet de
communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier voyager dans l'assiette nous
vous ferons découvrir la fougasse
catalan une brioche garni de crème
pâtissière et de fruits les expressions
populaires à présent être en ruine les
français disent avoir un chat dans la
gorge des espagnols eux disent avoir une
grenouille dans la gorge que dit-on
ailleurs c'est ce que nous verrons à la
fin de cette émission
mais avant que fait l'europe dans notre
région un exemple tout sonne robe
l'europe dans ma région
depuis 1995 l'association cbl réagir
oeuvre pour l'insertion des hommes et
des femmes par l'activité économique et
bénéficie du fonds social européen dans
différents projets pour en parler avec
nous je reçois aujourd'hui simon langue
dorff responsable du développement ces
belles réagir bonjour bonjour merci de
votre invitation
alors votre association concentre ses
missions autour de l'insertion
professionnelle est ce que la création
de ces belles réagir en 1995 répondait à
des besoins bien précis
oui la création de cv elle en 95
répondait à un objectif d'accompagnement
des demandeurs d'emploi du territoire
donc du territoire bien précis des
yvelines de la celle-saint-cloud
marly-le-roi plaisir saint cyr l'école
et donc à l'ouest jusqu'à montfort
l'amaury fait c'est un territoire qui
est délimité par le préfet par
l'administration et les yvelines sont
délimitées en quatre associations
intermédiaires comme la nôtre qui ont
chacun un territoire bien précis
d'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
de ce territoire presque en 2021 ces
besoins sont plus importants que dans
les années 90 par exemple oui
actuellement effectivement avec la crise
du coc vide je pense que on reçoit de
plus en plus de personnes on a
actuellement 300 salariés en insertion
qui se chiffre qui augmente avec des
nouveaux profils qui nous viennent des
gens plus qualifiés qui ont du mal à
retrouver un emploi
des profils de restaurateurs même de dj
qui viennent nous voir parce que en ce
moment ils n'ont pas de débouchés
alors justement pour bien expliquer à
nos auditeurs quels sont les objectifs
de ces belles réagir au quotidien alors
nos objectifs ils sont assez simple en
fait c'est d'accompagner les demandeurs
d'emploi vers un emploi durable donc un
cdd ou un cdi
donc nous on reçoit la personne on le
présente notre association et si elle
est d'accord elle s'inscrit au sein de
notre association on lui propose des
formations lui propose des missions de
courte ou de longue durée au sein
d'entreprises de collectivités ou chez
des particuliers et notre objectif c'est
qu'après deux ans ces personnes soient
embauchés en cdd ou en cdi
au sein d'une entreprise ou d'une
collectivité alors justement pour pour
permettre en fait ce retour à l'emploi
cette insertion professionnelle est-ce
que vous avez mis en place des
partenariats avec les différentes
collectivités par exemple est-ce que
vous êtes soutenus tout à fait par
différents sont greffés on a des
conventions avec presque chacune des
mairies de nos territoires
la celle-saint-cloud marly le roi
saint cyr et plaisirs les plus grosses
et on signe une convention annuelle en
fête qui leur permet de bénéficier de
tous nos services
durant toute l'année à un prix unique
pour toutes les prestations et avec avec
le marché de l'emploi inquiète de plus
en plus compliqué aujourd'hui est ce que
justement votre association a pour
objectif de de permettre une facilité
entre guillemets ou que ce soit plus
simple de s'insérer professionnellement
tout à fait nos salariés vont être
accompagnés pour par nos conseillers en
insertion professionnelle donc des mes
collègues qui sont diplômés pour
accompagner les salariés ils vont lever
les freins à l'emploi ils vont
travailler les la recherche d'emploi le
savoir être en entreprise
de mon côté moi je suis en charge de
développer les contrats avec les
entreprises ou les collectivités pour
leur fournir des missions donc
l'acquérir de l'expérience
professionnelle et à la suite de ça on
espère au bout de deux ans qu'il puisse
retrouver un cdd ou un cdi
alors qui peut faire appel à votre votre
association tout demandeur d'emploi tout
demandeur d'emploi enfin avec des
critères quand même précis ils doivent
être inscrits au pôle emploi depuis plus
d'un an
ou alors ça ce sont des personnes
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux
alors ou alors des personnes démunies de
toute ressource repris de l'aide sociale
ou de l'aide de la justice
est-ce que ce que malgré la crise
sanitaire vous avez réussi à a aidé les
demandeurs d'emploi oui oui notre
chiffre est en constante augmentation
notre activité aussi on est a pu elle a
plus de sept mille heures de travail
facturé au mois de mars donc notre
association se développe vraiment bien
et donc plus on a de clients plus on
peut accueillir des demandeurs d'emploi
pour les aider les accompagner au
quotidien
alors vous bénéficiez du fonds social
européen pour différents projets en
2016-2017 votre déploiement sur le
nouveau territoire de la plaine de
versailles vous a amené à recruter trois
collaborateurs pour assurer le
développement commercial vers les
entreprises et les collectivités ainsi
que l'accompagnement des demandeurs
d'emploi
depuis que le fonds social européen
soutient ces belles réagir est ce que
vos missions auprès des demandeurs
d'emploi puissent se développer ou en
tout cas se renforcer
alors notre association elle pourrait
fonctionner uniquement sur fonds propres
ça c'est vraiment une spécificité de
notre association qui est quand même
assez exceptionnel dans le milieu mais
le fse effectivement nous aident pour
l'accompagnement de nos salariés
donc c'est une somme assez conséquente
qui nous est versée par par cette
institution
pour donc accroître nos actions de
formation nos ateliers
les entretiens individuels qui sont
réalisés chaque semaine par par mes
collègues et donc effectivement bien sûr
c'est une somme qui nous qui nous aide
comme celle de l'état ou de la région
qui est non négligeable mais comme comme
je les dis grâce à nos clients pourrait
s'en sortir sans ces formats sens sans
ces subventions
alors justement vous l'avez un petit peu
expliqué donc il ya le fse et le fonds
social européen et vous êtes aussi
soutenu par par la région la région
voilà aussi par la direccte aussi et par
la région ile de france
et qu'est ce que vous avez pu mettre en
place grâce à ce fonds social européen
est-ce que déjà le projet je parle de
2016 2017 est ce que c'est justement un
projet en continu oui en 2000 2016-2017
ça nous a permis d'accompagner 150
salariés donc subventionné par par cette
institution
en 2010 9 81 et en 2020 100 salariés qui
bénéficient de cette subvention pour
pour notre accompagnement pour plus
d'informations un site existe ww points
cbl réagir coin fr comme chaque semaine
nous vous faisons découvrir celles et
ceux qui ont participé à la construction
européenne
aujourd'hui l'allemand conrad adenauer
son parcours avec la maison de l'europe
et le centre d'information europe direct
sous drop
conrad adenauer est un homme politique
allemand né en 1876 à cologne après des
études de droit il entre dans un cabinet
d'avocats puis commence sa carrière
politique dans la république de weimar
il devient le plus jeune maire de
cologne en 1917 de 1921 à 1933 il est
président du conseil d'état de prusse sa
carrière est brusquement interrompue par
la prise de contrôle nazis en 1933 démis
par hermann goering de toutes ses
fonctions en raison de son hostilité
affichée au nazisme il refusait par
exemple d'arborer le drapeau nazi à côté
du drapeau allemand
il est emprisonné brièvement après la
nuit des longs couteaux en 1934 puis
entre en juillet et novembre 1944 après
l'attentât contre hitler en juillet ce
n'est qu'après la seconde guerre
mondiale en septembre 1949 que le
parlement fédéral allemand lui confie le
premier poste de chancelier de la
république fédérale d'allemagne qu'il
occupera jusqu'en 1963 période à clé
l'air adenauer
il est considéré comme le fondateur de
l'allemagne moderne adenauer travail
fortement pour l'intégration européenne
de l'allemagne
ils signent successivement les traité
créant la ceca et la cee l'allemagne est
l'un des membres fondateurs de ces
traités et rejoint le conseil de
l'europe en 1951 et l'otan en 1955 le
chancelier allemand se penche
particulièrement sur une coopération en
matière de défense européenne cette
coopération a débuté en 1949
puis s'est poursuivie pendant la guerre
de corée et les discussions
internationales
l'idée se concrétise avec le projet de
la communauté européenne de défense
c'est ed l'idée partagée avec jean
monnet et de créer une armée européenne
composée de contingents allemand le
traité signé par les six états
fondateurs de l'europe
cependant il est rejeté en 1954 par
l'assemblée nationale française ce qui a
ralenti pendant un certain temps le
processus d'unification européenne sa
volonté de réconcilier la france et
l'allemagne après la seconde guerre
mondiale est plus forte et c'est pour
lui la clé pour maintenir une europe
pacifique et unis cette amitié franco
allemande est scellée en 1963 avec le
traité de l'elysée signé par de gaulle
et adenauer le 22 janvier 2-1 par la
suite la journée franco-allemande qui
célèbre l'union entre les deux pays
conrad adenauer cite souvent l'idée de
victor hugo des états unis d'europe pour
une union économique qui mènera à une
entente politique entre les pays
il est la cible de nombreuses critiques
qui voient l'intégration de l'allemagne
en europe comme un obstacle à la
réunification du pays
il soutiendra durant quatorze ans que la
réunification européenne mettra fin à la
division de l'allemagne
malheureusement malgré sa politique
volontariste il ne peut que subir
l'édification du mur de berlin en 1961
il démissionne en octobre 1963 et meurt
quelques années plus tard en 1967
place maintenant à notre invité
politique cohérente à alonso reçoit
l'eurodéputée sylvie brunet zone europe
l'invité politique bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputé membre de la commission de
l'emploi et des affaires sociales du
parlement européen et membre du groupe
renew europe alors avec vous c'est donc
de l'emploi et des conditions de travail
dont nous allons nous intéresser
aujourd'hui avec vous il ya quelques
mois vous avez évoqué un phénomène
croissant celui de la pauvreté des
travailleurs en soulignant que la part
des travailleurs européens exposés au
risque de pauvreté était de 9 4% en 2018
soit plus d'un point par rapport à il ya
dix ans alors est-ce que vous pensez que
la crise sanitaire va accélérer ce
phénomène écoutez malheureusement et
même si dans le plan d'action pour
mettre en oeuvre le socle européen des
droits sociaux
il ya bien inscrire les l'idée de
diminuer le nombre de personnes en
situation de grande pauvreté
malheureusement compte tenu de cette
crise sanitaire tout les alertes heures
sont en place pour dire que hélas
nombre de personnes en situation de
pauvreté augmente alors on ne serait ce
que le phénomène des jeunes on voit que
sur 2020 le chômage des jeunes a déjà
augmenté de 2 3% dans l'union européenne
en 2020 alors qu'on était plutôt sur des
bons signaux et donc tout cela indique
les plus vulnérables vont effectivement
être plus concernés par cette crise
sanitaire dont on espère sortir le plus
vite possible et que peut faire l'europe
sur cette question le plan de relance
européen est ce qu'il va pouvoir
atténuer les effets de la crise est-ce
que c'est prévu pour
alors où il le plan de relance européen
heureusement a pris en compte ce sujet
social nous sommes d'ailleurs beaucoup
intervenu sur le point on a beaucoup
insisté pour dire attention on peut pas
se contenter que de la relance
économique
attention au social et donc notamment
dans l'agglo cadre de la négociation du
cadre budgétaire 2021 et 2027 sur le fse
le fse fonds social européen puce a été
augmentée 3 % vont être dédiés au
minimum là aussi la famille beaucoup se
battre à l'aide aux plus démunis puisque
le fonds européen d'aidé aux plus
démunis maintenant fondu dans le fse
plus est dans le cadre de réactifs qui
est parti une partie du plan de relance
vraiment dédié à l'accompagnement de la
crise et à la sortie de crise il ya
également un sujet social des fonds
dédiés aux plus jeunes justement sur les
plus vénérables autour de la garantie
genèse d'un investissement dans les
compétences pour que tous les états
membres et un minimum de fonds dédié
aussi à la jeunesse
donc ça a été plus en compte dans plan
de relance plusieurs études ont
également montré que les travailleuses
les plus touchés avait plus souffert de
la crise que les travailleurs est ce que
c'est ce que vous avez également
constaté oui globalement
beaucoup d'études là dessus les femmes
là aussi c'est malheureusement un
principe simple et plus vulnérables sont
les plus touchés et les femmes sont
souvent dans des situations plus
vulnérables soient en situation de
famille monoparentale soit sur des
secteurs plus exposés comme le soin le
service à la personne ou du coup elles
ont été plus exposés à la maladie à la
pandémie aussi plus de femmes dans des
emplois
ils ont du travail non décent dissimulé
donc pas reconnu officiellement on en a
plus dans le cadre des cartes d'enfants
de l'aide de la garde de personnes âgées
donc du coup qui se sont retrouvés plus
exposés et sans travail mais aussi on a
eu tout les domaines du télétravail jeu
aussi où les femmes ont été plus
affectées par ce qu'elles ont toujours
plus de charges au niveau familial dans
leur notamment en termes de risques
psychosociaux et de conditions de
travail donc qu'aux vidéos et je ne
parle même pas des violences faites aux
femmes ont chacun sait quand on a eu une
augmentation 30 % environ des violences
faites aux femmes pendant cette crise
sanitaire
la lutte n'est que pour l'égalité femmes
hommes doit être encore plus renforcé
aujourd'hui il faut aller encore plus
loin
elle est absolument et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que fort heureusement nous
travaillons sur au moins deux sujets la
directive qui vient d'être proposée sur
la transparence des salaires pour lutter
contre les écarts salariaux entre les
femmes et des hommes en europe
donc ça va être un sujet très important
pour que plus de transparence des
rémunérations le salaire minimum qui
compte va concerner beaucoup de femmes
aussi dans l'union européenne
et bien évidemment aussi un plan pour
lutter contre les violences faites aux
femmes donc plus que jamais bien sûr
qu'il faut renforcer nos actions en
europe pour réduire les écarts et des
inégalités alors autre thème les
conditions de travail dans le secteur de
l'aviation qui représente arrêtez moi si
je me trompe près de 6 millions
d'emplois
c'est un secteur qui était déjà très
concurrentiel avant la crise et la crise
sanitaire aujourd'hui n'a rien arrangé
alors en préparant cette émission j'ai
découvert qu'il existait pour le
personnel navigant et même les pilotes
des contrats de travail différents et
très varié selon les pays
européens et que dans certains cas
certains personnels devaient même payé
pour voler je voudrais que vous nous
dresser un petit peu l'état des lieux de
ce secteur
oui alors c'est vrai que ce secteur
quand on regarde les emplois indirects
c'est près de 9 4 millions d'emplois
dans l'union européenne
bien sûr tout cela en ce moment on sait
particulièrement affectées
mais malgré des interventions multiples
notamment règlement 2008 qui déjà
demandé à ce qu'il y ait un statut du
personnel navigant est donc dans le
secteur de l'aviation
pour toutes ces raisons mais aussi 2015
la commission qui s'est réengagé à ce
qu'il y ait un statut plus uniforme en
europe malgré tout ça on a vu se
multiplier
ce qu'on appelle le pay to fly donc
c'est vraiment payé pour voler on se
retrouve quasiment avec des personnels
navigants qui doivent se payer eux mêmes
leur status je puis dire avec des
statuts de travail indépendant dans
certains cas bon pas vraiment justifié
beaucoup de différences d'un pays à
l'autre et ce qui est important c'est la
notion de lieu principal d'activité
c'est ce qu'on doit regarder nous au
niveau européen pour dire de quels
contrats de travail de quel statut de
travail relève alors on a eu
effectivement ce phénomène avec beaucoup
de jurisprudence les compagnies
aériennes certaines essayant de trouver
de meilleurs statuts possible et en
rendant plus vénérables ce personnel
navigant voilà donc ça c'est un vrai
sujet effectivement le statut de ces
personnes qui qui par définition bout
d'un pays à l'autre
avec ce fameux pays to fly contre lequel
il faut quand même se battre et vous
donc je te ment tant qu'eurodéputé vous
prenez quoi une harmonisation
oui moi je prône
effectivement une harmonisation une
meilleure définition justement ce que je
disais le lieu principal d'activité la
base de travail au moins être sur ce
qu'on met dans ce statut en se basant là
dessus quel est le mur de départ on ne
passait plus de temps même s'ils ont des
personnels navigants
et puis c'est tout le sujet de l'europe
sociale
et cette fameuse mobilité en ce moment
un peu mise à mal mais qui va repartir
où on ne doit pas voir se multiplier des
statuts très différents d'un pays à
l'autre sinon les entreprises s'en
saisissent et vont aller toujours à
l'endroit où le statut lorraine plus
favorable et pas forcément je peux voilà
être plus avantageux et c'est pas
forcément plus avantageux évidemment
pour les travailleurs qui sont sont plus
en situation de faiblesse
autre secteur la livraison l'entreprise
de livraison de repas justin concurrents
du mérite et de des livres ou veut
embaucher 4500 livreur en d'ici la fin
de l'année
mais pour vous c'est une opération de
communication où ça va dans le bon sens
une bonne chose je ne sais pas si c'est
une opération de communication pour être
très honnête
après c'est leur choix statutaire c'est
tout le débat en ce moment sur les
livreurs puisque moi je je suis
rapporteur sur les conditions de travail
des travailleurs des plateformes sur un
rapport d'initiative et qu'on va avoir
sûrement une directive
on a tout un débat dans l'union
européenne et même en france sur le
statut qu'ils doivent avoir
est ce que ce sont des vrais
travailleurs indépendants ou pas alors
dans un certain nombre de cas et de
critères notamment pour la livraison on
va peut-être pouvoir analyser qui sont
en fait salariés maintenant est ce qu'il
faut le systématiser
on va voir si on arrive à des bons
critères just hits on nous les sites
souvent d'abord j'attends de voir
combien de personnes y vont exactement
recruter et puis est-ce que ça va
convenir ou pas on verra bien mais il
est vrai que dans un certain nombre de
situations ses défauts travailleurs
indépendants donc à partir du moment où
ils sont pas bien rémunéré par rapport à
leur travail pas protégés en termes de
maladie d'accident du travail devrait
être plutôt relations de travail salarié
et donc c'est vrai que ça va plutôt dans
le bon sens si on arrive à ça alors vous
vous n'êtes pas naturellement contre les
plateformes les entrepreneurs c'est
juste que vous voulez éviter certaines
dérives donc il ya un besoin d'encadrer
quelles sont les pistes aujourd'hui sur
lesquels vous travaillez pour justement
cet encadrement alors les pistes sur
lesquelles on travaille c'est d'abord de
regarder quel est le minimum de
protection sociale et de droit qui
doivent avoir ça c'est la première chose
importante
deuxièmement pour que tout ça s'améliore
était bien ce minimum qu'on soit
travailleurs indépendants ou qu'on soit
salarié on doit avoir cette protection
il ya la négociation collective et donc
dans les pistes il faut ouvrir la
possibilité de discuter de ses
conditions de travail aux travailleurs
indépendants
ce que là
les règles de la concurrence en europe
et ne permettent pas de faire parce que
travailler en indépendant même un
chauffeur dans dtc il a assimilé à une
entreprise
donc il peut pas discuter avec les
autres sur ses conditions de travail les
conditions de fise que vont lui donner
les plateformes et donc ça déjà il faut
qu'on y remédie d'ailleurs en france on
est en train de faire et troisièmement
une meilleure protection vis-à-vis des
logiciels des algorithmes parce que
quelquefois il ya des changements dans
les galeries sur leur temps de travail
sur leurs conditions de travail sont pas
vraiment informés ils savent pas à quoi
s'attendre
comment ça va interagir sur leurs
activités et ça c'est vraiment un vrai
problème mais définir cette protection
sociale qu'ils doivent tous avoir et
déjà ça va dans le sens des travaux
antérieurs du conseil et de l'europe de
manière générale merci beaucoup sylvie
brunet est revenu dans une europe
si je rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputé
membre de la commission de l'emploi et
des affaires sociales et membre du
groupe
renew europe tiens vous pour voyager
avec nous il vous faut une serviette et
découvert nous vous invitons comme
chaque semaine à voyager dans l'assiette
jean-marc d'ambroise chef pâtissier à
bessancourt dans le val d'oise nous
présente la fougasse catalan zone europe
voyage
bonjour je me présente jean marc dambre
aux chefs pâtissiers
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter la
fougasse catalan cette fougueuse vient
de perpignan dont je suis originaire
aujourd'hui je vais vous la présenter en
version pizza et fruité donc pour cette
fugace il va nous falloir de la farine
de la levure de l'eau des oeufs du sel
du sucre et rien de plus j'ajoute alors
ma farine mon sucre le sel la levure du
beurre et bien sûr d'eux
du coup pour pétrir notre pâte à brioche
que nous allons utiliser un crochet
ainsi qu'un batteur
nous le mettons à tourner en premières
minutes pendant six minutes et bien sûr
nous allons ajouter l'eau
nous allons disposer la pâte sur plaque
et la mettre à lever pendant deux heures
à 26 degrés température ambiante pour
faire une bonne fougasse catalan bien
sûr il nous faut de la crème pâtissière
que j'ai préparé en amont et que je vais
disposer sur mon rond de pâte briochée
du coup nous allons badigeonner un peu
de blanc d'oeuf sur les bords de la pâte
afin de lui apporter un peu de brillance
après cuisson
maintenant c'est parti nous allons
préchauffez le four à 180 et l'enfourner
puis baissez la température à 160° et la
cuire pendant 15 minutes
allez c'est parti on enfourne à notre
fougasse catalan
après quinze minutes de cuisson nous
allons sortir notre fougue catalane
donc nous allons ajouter ce joli nappage
abricots sur les bords de notre fougue
catalane
puis nous allons ajouter du sucre au
grain sur les côtés mais nous allons
parsemé de sucre glace sur les côtés
pour lui donner une petite touche
d'originalité
vous pouvez la déguster comme ceux ci en
version crème pâtissière ou simplement
la découvrit de fruits frais aujourd'hui
je vais vous faire une fougasse ruth et
à la fraise
maintenant nous allons écouter les
fraises après les avoir lavé pour les
disposer sur notre fougue à ce fruité et
les disposer comme ceci
notre fougasse fruité à la fraise est
terminée nous allons à présent la
badigeonner de nappage abricots avant la
dégustation
et voilà à présent notre fougasse fruité
catalan est terminée nous allons à
présent à déguster les expressions
populaires être enrouée les français
disent avoir un chat dans la gorge et
les allemands disent avoir une
grenouille dans la gorge que dit-on
ailleurs regardez zone europe
expression d'ici et d'ailleurs en
allemagne on dit alain roche mariage ce
qui signifie avoir une grenouille dans
la gorge
en italie on dit un verre au springboard
là ce qui veut dire avoir un crapaud
dans la gorge
or minimes ont dit freud in one foot ce
qui signifie avoir une grenouille dans
la gorge en espagne ou bi tenir
normalement la verglas avoir une graine
wind dans la gorge et on dit aussi avoir
une dans la gorge zone europe c'est
terminé pour aujourd'hui merci aux
équipes techniques du parlement européen
de bruxelles
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations et
aussi sur tv 78 rendez vous la semaine
prochaine
très bonne soirée sous une robe sûr
sensation